nutriólogos midieron el contenido de
azúcar en gramos de 32 bebidas de
starbucks a continuación podemos ver la
gráfica de la frecuencia relativa
acumulada queremos subrayar esta parte
frecuencia relativa acumulada así es que
por aquí tenemos la gráfica en el eje
horizontal tenemos distintas cantidades
de azúcar en gramos y en el eje vertical
tenemos la frecuencia relativa acumulada
pero bueno empecemos asegurándonos de
que sabemos cómo leer esta gráfica por
ejemplo por aquí este punto nos está
diciendo que el 0% de las bebidas de
star box tiene 0 gramos de azúcar o
menos o sea que el 0 por ciento de las
bebidas de starbucks no contienen azúcar
pero ahora vamos con este otro punto que
se encuentra en el eje horizontal en 5
gramos y en el eje vertical en la
frecuencia relativa acumulada 0.1
es que lo que este punto nos dice es que
0.1 o sea el 10% de todas las bebidas de
star box tienen 5 gramos de azúcar o
menos y por otro lado este otro punto
por acá nos dice que el 100 por ciento
de las bebidas de starbucks tiene un
contenido de azúcar de 50 gramos o menos
porque aquí tenemos la frecuencia
relativa acumulada creo entonces por
aquí este punto nos da la frecuencia de
bebidas de star box que tienen 5 gramos
o menos y por eso es que esta gráfica va
creciendo porque vamos acumulando
bebidas porque conforme vamos agregando
azúcar una mayor cantidad de bebidas de
starbucks tienen esa cantidad de azúcar
o menos y por lo tanto la frecuencia
aumenta pero bueno vamos con la primera
pregunta un café con hielo tiene 15
gramos de azúcar estima el percentil
entero más cercano
esta bebida así es que nuestro café con
hielo tiene 15 gramos de azúcar por aquí
están los 15 gramos de azúcar y ahora
estimamos el percentil más cercano
entonces nos vamos hacia la gráfica y
mira aquí incluso tienen un dato
y podemos observar que es 0.2 o sea el
20% del total de las bebidas de
starbucks tienen 15 gramos de azúcar o
menos entonces el percentil de esta
bebida si lo estimamos con esta gráfica
que nos dieron es 0.2 aunque la
frecuencia relativa acumulada es 0.2 por
lo tanto el percentil de esta bebida es
20% otra forma de verlo más fácil es
convertir esto a porcentajes aunque ya
que vivíamos que el 20 por ciento de las
bebidas de starbucks tiene 15 gramos de
azúcar o menos y entonces un café con
hielo está en el percentil 20 pero bueno
vamos con la siguiente pregunta estima
la mediana de la distribución de las
bebidas y tenemos una pista piensa en el
percentil 50 empecemos recordando que es
la mediana para obtener la mediana lo
que hacemos es ordenar a todas las
bebidas y fijarnos en cuál queda en
medio
esto es equivalente a tomar el percentil
50 entonces nos vamos aquí a la
frecuencia relativa acumulada y para
obtener el percentil 50 buscamos la
frecuencia relativa acumulada 0.5 la
cual está por acá por aquí tenemos el 0
por aquí tenemos la frecuencia relativa
acumulada 0.5 y si nos vamos para acá y
bajamos para ver la cantidad del
contenido de azúcar entonces estamos por
aquí en una frecuencia relativa
acumulada de 0.5 y nos vamos hacia la
gráfica y así encontramos cuántos gramos
de azúcar se necesitan para tener una
frecuencia relativa acumulada de 0.5 y
parece que estos son 25 gramos entonces
cómo podemos interpretar esto es que el
50 por ciento de las bebidas tienen 25
gramos de azúcar o menos por lo que 25
gramos es una muy buena estimación de la
mediana del
dato que se encuentra justo en medio de
todos así es que podemos decir que la
mediana es aproximadamente 25 gramos
pero bueno vamos a hacer otro ejercicio
con exactamente el mismo conjunto de
datos bueno por aquí nos preguntan cuál
es la mejor estimación del rango inter
cuartil de la distribución de las
bebidas y bueno para encontrar el rango
inter cuartil lo que hacemos es buscar
el percentil 25 y luego también buscar
el percentil 75 y la resta de estos dos
es el rango inter cuartil entonces pues
vamos a hacer justo eso empecemos
buscando el percentil 25 aunque nos
vamos a la frecuencia relativa acumulada
buscamos punto 25 por aquí tenemos punto
entonces punto 25 está por acá y nos
vamos hacia la gráfica y luego vemos su
contenido de azúcar y llega
más o menos por aquí y entonces el
percentil 25 es esta cantidad de gramos
de azúcar que pues lo estamos estimando
entonces podemos decir que es más o
menos 18 estamos estimando que el
percentil 25 son 18 gramos
aproximadamente lo que estamos diciendo
aquí es que aproximadamente el 25 por
ciento de las bebidas tiene 18 gramos o
menos pero bueno ahora tenemos que
calcular el percentil 75 ok entonces nos
vamos a la frecuencia relativa acumulada
punto 75 tenemos puntos 6 es 3.7
entonces punto 75 está más o menos por
aquí nos vamos hacia la gráfica y esto
nos da una cantidad de gramos de azúcar
de más o menos no sé yo diría que como
39 que íbamos a poner por aquí que son
aproximadamente 39 gramos de azúcar y
entonces cuál es la diferencia entre
estos dos bueno
pues la diferencia entre estos dos es de
aproximadamente 21 gramos así es que
nuestra estimación del rango inter
cuartil fijándonos en la frecuencia
relativa acumulada de la distribución de
estas bebidas es 21 lo primero que
hicimos fue fijarnos en el percentil 25
ok entonces observamos que el 25 por
ciento de las bebidas tienen 18 gramos
de azúcar o menos aproximadamente y
luego también observamos que el 75 por
ciento de las bebidas tiene 39 gramos o
menos y si tomamos la resta entre estos
2 cuartiles este es el primer cuartil y
este es el tercer cuarto si tomamos la
resta entre ellos obtenemos el rango
inter cuartil y en este caso la resta
nos dio 21 gramos pero ahora tenemos que
observar qué opciones tenemos lo que
tenemos por aquí 10 gramos 20 gramos 30
o 40 gramos
la opción que más se acerca a nuestra
estimación son 20 gramos y listo